and our dragon marriage that's what I'm
talking about but most important of it
all the one thing that truly mattered 2
million at the PD PI submission
subreddit let's get it gamers I'm so
happy
everything is happening at once perfect
timing good job guys
did I just yeah glad we have this okay
let's get into the memes
congratulations Felix and Marcia this is
so sweet the most awful thing on my
subreddit thank you guys
what a nice wedding gift hey it's
another congratulations except with less
upvotes epic felix and marcia all the
people in the sub a congratulation me on
every wedding post there you have it
just so we're clear I'm doing a separate
hundred million sub Club video Bing bong
PewDiePie's first photo and his most
recent photo on Instagram Jace is so
sweet I really want to thank whoever
photoshopped this because now every time
I see the photo with Marcia this thing
just pops in my head thank you for the
permanent brain destruct in whatever
that's cute that's a cute photo a truly
epic gaming a moment anime live accent
remake no then the Minecraft what is
better come on it it was men marrying
his boyfriend come on that's way more
epic oh and my ranks win merch I even
realized epic it's happening ah yeah I
guess my parents broke the news my dad
Jurgen Klopp get in the boat
ah smell and friends boyfriend is there
that is so sweet it's actually what
we're doing for our honeymoon and then
we're going through that friction water
sure hey have you guys noticed who else
was there
none need
Oh Mike I respect that that makes me
happy
this truly puts a smile on my face when
you scroll so far down you see Keanu
Reeves again where have you been I
didn't even scroll far but okay cool I'm
so happy for them you did it you crazy
son of a [ __ ] you did it this is sick
six hours ago hundred thousand
subscribers baby can we see the passing
nope all right all right cool the fact
that we did it just before you have
changed their system so cool oh yeah I
need to improve lava tower they that's
adorable
I'll make it better I promise let's not
forget about this guy that's all right
we can we can forget about this guy it's
it's fine Thank You Bros you made all my
dreams come true this was back in 2011
imagine how I'm feeling right now I came
from the future the bro army has take
over the world and you have 100 million
I don't know if this is real but I'm too
lazy to check up looked thank you
long live the king people for help okay
I can't believe this you betrayed me
I'm fed up with this world you can't
trust your king then who can you trust
ninety-nine point eight million nine
year old armor we're almost there
we did it I can't believe we did it oh
this our wedding video that was an
amazing film I'm very glad how that turn
out here to show it the asset is
throwing the bridal suite to my jet
under wedding night on the day of pills
and my wedding wedding ends marzia where
is the car feeling get in the boat
I don't need to abduct her I were
already married okay a petition to a
Dalloway award to every meme that gets
to the why hmm
will this one make it perhaps Felix
you're not allowed to upload nor vlog on
your honeymoon and that's a fact
well I have one video that will go up
why is my face cropped up halfway this
is a good crop guys just look
I have some videos going up when I'm
away I'm going tomorrow actually or by
the time this video goes up but there
won't be any of the Minecraft series
because those take too much time to edit
and obviously I don't have I don't have
time to do that the Royal Wedding the
actual wedding gets meri there it is
about to hit 100 million subscribers
about to defeat the Ender Dragon submit
it to Lily
God can you guys space it out just a
little bit that'd be great thank you
I'll see you guys at a thousand millions
but I just say I thought yeah that's
what I meant before after mob farm okay
that's actually a really good idea
that's gonna take a lot of material
yeah that's though I'll do that it'll be
a big project
PewDiePie pose the wedding pictures on
Instagram world record egg chuckles I
mean danger does any have like 65
million likes or something
I think it's fine the egg will be
contained no problem PewDiePie gets
married the entire I didn't think it
would be that big of a deal but I'm so
glad so many people are happy for me it
really means a lot they dressed like
Edgar and Maya aha we couldn't sadly not
bring them to that venue but we did do
some photos the day before with them I
yes yes that was the inspiration we just
looked at our dogs and was like this can
you make this
I do think I'd like to take a break at
some point it would be nice it's a cave
here you go when you feel like it thanks
guys
then I leave everyone's like we're at a
my crap all congratulations meme
community
oh my [ __ ] shell bag it's enough to make
a grown man cry
I congratulations it's a celebration
party all day I don't know you I can't
sing it you beg it's a congratulations
like a it's a celebration I just want to
tell you that I think that you're
amazing it said that on Dave's
congratulations cards a congratulations
I'm so bummed that we didn't play it at
the wedding it'd have been so perfect
we didn't play [ __ ] lasagna and my mom
sang it at the top of
and it was very wholesome fun moment
what do you got for me
useless oh my god that's so awful it's
not my fault that the game is designed
this way okay not my fault
you cannot hold me accountable just
notice the gun no no stop the moment you
realize that if Pearson Marcia have a
kid we will not be the bros we will then
be the uncles yes I'll go fast gamers
wait Sweden congratulated me thank you
sweetie
very cool ahahaha hey thanks sweetie
Felix you can be whatever you want
Marcia I want to be swims mother it's a
tired surprise tomorrow is Felix and my
cs8 anniversary ah we look so cute in
these photos and it's also our wedding
day we thought for sure people would
figure it out like with the date being
so obvious and people knew it would
happen this year we were just worried
that like pres would come or something
crazy but it didn't everything went
perfect I'm so happy I still enjoy
YouTube I have no plans for quitting but
this is peak I hope we understand that
this this I don't see how anything more
positive can come at the same time
thousand million subs oh what a cute fan
art that's so nice you know it's a
special day for Felix because he just
grew that's right I grew a pair of legs
I had to cut him off at the end of the
day dinnerbone girlfriend that's a great
name baby pie when he sees his own child
for the first time
why is that funny it's really bad
[Laughter]
skip past what happened to banks name
tag the prophecy is true the Council of
water sheep push pills into water twice
to try and warn him about pee pee poop
was betrayal oh my god
the story writes itself
incredible can we
talk about whoever does the subtitles
were for Felix videos happy might say
noises unfortunately I had to turn off
subtitles because people keep promoting
their own damn channels it's so annoying
I'm sorry if you rely on subtitles I
hope we can get back soon when you push
pits to the portal just to make sure no
more animals oh no you guys haven't seen
the episode yet or maybe you have I
don't know if I'll go up today or the
day after
oh that's such a nice fan art that's so
cute my stuck it turned out it then mats
yeah I can't wait to be your husband it
all happened so fast
yeah I thought I would throw you guys
off a bit by saying it because you
wouldn't expect it to happen the day
after if I say it right
or would you know I'm not crying he's
dead that's put a smile on my face look
my ring we got it in Japan and it spins
and now it's a different ring epic epic
me person that said Felix should vlog
his honeymoon one video you'll get one
video and that's it man I can't wait I'm
gonna be surfing that's my dream
I just want to surf that's all I want
not think about uploading even though I
will upload all in wait it doesn't
matter I swear this is not what it looks
like looks like the zombie got some
creeper head you know cuz you can he can
drop his head okay moving on
oh my god yeah Felix gave us a daisies
in real life and in mine crime oh my god
[Laughter]
didn't even realize I just knew she
likes loves flowers
I mean Felix I'm enjoying editing my own
videos against unemployment no cyber is
killing it like he's still editing most
of the videos can we get some size
appreciation in the Shatt doing a 12
hour stream at 100 million doing a 12
hour stream at 100 million and donating
the money to rain forest I like that I
would love to do a charity like that or
turn the event to a charity thing I will
have to do the live stream when I'm back
from the honeymoon I'm sorry
literally leaving tomorrow I didn't
think things would go so fast ah YouTube
said Congrats
that's hey hey last thing monitor see
before we hit a hundred million not this
video though I'm sorry it will be the
next the next one I made spend thousand
tumor simulator that's so cool that's so
dope oh stop stop when you get to attend
Puetz wedding because you got his chair
in to rewind twenty yes that is
absolutely what happened when everyone
talks about Marcia and no one mentions
the new outro sad Mya noises damn we
both look good in that old black suit
baby
mmm you know I know I wanted to do or
black for my wedding but damn I didn't
think we'd both look so goddamn good in
his latest video Felix said he was busy
and couldn't mine crap he was actually
getting married defensively why even on
his wedding
this is an appreciation and gratitude
post appreciation to Sai for editing it
okay let me guess your family it was and
it was beautiful ah Felix you strike him
with lightning so you should make it
zombie pigmen and head out right now
that's a good idea
creep good ideas like that coming I like
that I like that a lot Felix do not
throw your training and avoid it will
not come back and you will lose it well
I wish I knew this before when you
realize what if she was warning Pierce
about the great people to be the great
should we name our home potato proud
Irish noises 100 million is it's great
and all but can we appreciate those
beads I am back bro army veterans only
real veterans can understand be baby
Bubba how high can you dig he's speaking
the language of gods how I shall we take
this turtle
these are great memes oh if we can get
1500 bill before somebody it would be a
wedding to thank you guys thank you
Cambridge Oh another amazing planner
when will your wife host me review well
first we have to get married that is a
requirement
well-well whip we got another one boys
artist after minecraft episode how did
they draw so fast honestly some are just
like what I just published haha let's
insane but we'll start the dampers yeah
took eight hours slow artist how is that
slow when you realize Pierce wants to
cry the entire video but tries his heart
is not too well no I I don't think I but
hey if that makes you feel more
emotional epic Felix in wedding pictures
Felix in [ __ ] Weimar Sarah laughing so
harlot that still image might said
desecrates the counsel of what the Sheep
Marcia has her first minecraft death by
drowning in water this just put a smile
on my no wait that isn't it nobody is
bored cool except of course sigh one who
did not attend the wedding to grind
videos consistently for us thank you for
your efforts I'm very cool yes we should
now update the brofist although
technically that's my other hand so
those I couldn't make any sense waiting
for the second he hits hundred million
to release hundred million Club oh my
god why am i it's so hot that I don't
even have it yet but it's out now for
the amazing price of 399 100 million
Claud March and that looks good are you
part of the club
check out represent a conversation feed
about epic can we just point out how
generally happy Felix's dad looks
you mean Jurgen Klopp long live the king
baby Papa oh my god that is epic the
Council of water shape that is so cool
Nick
we'll decide your fate oh my god yeah
except the dog killed her but you know
all right
oh there's so many cute bad arts a
little sleepy girls wallpaper boys
wallpaper I can't afford merge so I just
skip the ads ah ha ha ha petition for
peered stoop me know everyone when my
see accidentally broke the counsel of
sheeps peepee poo-poo pushes Felix into
the end portal also peepee poo-poo wow
that's so weird Felix is disappeared The
Betrayal guys we can save the Amazon
share to raise awareness Kenan Skyblock
part poor Ken and Felix wedding poet I
got him oh I need this so you can't mind
the ender dragon egg it will teleport
away to collect it miner block under it
then put a torch so it falls and you
will collect it boots doesn't cry during
emotional video cries when is Felix on
episode 50 so I made some updates to the
Frick chamber oh my god yes my greatest
creation the Frick chamber will reach
this cast one day the skies when
PewDiePie's may is happy making videos
about to get married and about to hit
100 million subscribers oh yeah
it's all coming together I feel so
fortunate and so lucky it's unbelievable
I am just so happy
Oh sweeties happiness noises ah Thank
You gamers brofist
coming soon 12 hour livestream coming
soon I just got a go on honeymoon and
I'll be right back ok gamers don't
forget about me while I'm going thank
you my bike you haven't tried to pursue
me later citizen e after 50 million our
troops
Miami down just down it's still relevant
just down a bit